i have a plan to travel the world a
little bit while i'm doing this youtube
tech thing so i'm selling my house and
i'm moving to hawaii and then after
hawaii i'm moving to austin texas and
then after austin texas i'm moving to
japan or switzerland we'll see and just
kind of take it in an environment before
i like actually do developer advocacy
[Music]
hi all and welcome to mooco's corner
mooco's corner is a show about leading a
life that feels more you in your life
and tech career i'm your host mayuko and
invite you to come in sit down maybe get
some hot chocolate cause tis the season
and enjoy the show
so today on the show we have none other
than jeremiah peoples he's a software
engineer with a self-taught background
who also makes content online about tech
and lifestyle he recently is taking a
kind of a break from like air force
stuff to do full-time youtube which we
were just talking about before the show
so i'm really excited to talk about that
hey jeremiah how's it going
it's it's going it's going well a bit
overwhelmed with life but uh happy to be
here yay well i'm so glad you're here i
think i probably asked on twitter i was
just like who should be on my show and
then i think you were like me me and i
was like yeah
[Laughter]
why not so uh jeremiah we've known each
other for i mean we've seen each other
on the internet for a long time but i
think we started talking to each other
more in the last few months or something
you were in my self-taught developer
video
we've like synced once or twice outside
of that i'm genuinely so happy to share
the space on youtube with you
and content and stuff like that your
stuff is so funny like your skits are
like so good so thank you
i was just watching your um imposter
syndrome video too about how you
overcame imposter syndrome at your first
internship at vmware which i thought was
so good i love the way that you tell the
story so
fan of you and your content so i'm glad
to just kind of like hang out and talk
and chill i'm gonna go score it today
same here yeah i think you and jarvis
were the first two engineer youtubers
that i watched to like really get
inspired to become a software engineer
this was like back when you were at
patreon years ago the good old days
yeah
well uh so this episode we're actually
filming this in early november but
it's likely going to come out in like
mid-december-ish so like holiday time
getting ready for 2022 times so
i want to ask you jeremiah how's your
year been how has 2021 been for you 2021
has been uh pretty great i'm teaching
which is really amazing i um half i'm
leaving the military so i need to hire
replacements so i had a higher
replacement i get to teach them all the
things that i've been learning over the
last two years which is my favorite
thing to do is the teaching that's
awesome i mean they say that like one of
the ways that you really know a concept
or like one of the ways to really
reinforce a concept is to teach others
and so that that sounds fun that's cool
too that you get the chance to actually
like train somebody so that there's not
like
a big gap in knowledge or anything like
that right right right yeah it's like a
long i think you mentioned you you've
been kind of like working to
like
what's the verb like d enlist like
finish your enlistment separate yeah
just separate out of the airport just
kind of transition
which has been super difficult to do
they they get uh they dropped orders on
me to go to germany to live and work and
i was like uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this whole
youtube thing if you don't mind so i'm
trying to deny them so it's been a
hassle trying to get out but it's
working out yeah and i heard i think
your most recent video you're talking
about how you're like you quit your job
you said it's been kind of like an
eight-month process right to leave i'm
starting an eight-month process so i
have like 60 days of vacation time that
i haven't used so i'm using that now and
then after my vacation time i get the
six-month internship where i'm working
full-time youtubing awesome and you're
interning with chris shawn right
yeah he again one of the first youtubers
i looked at to see oh you don't have to
go to college to be an engineer and then
i watched him did his thing and now i'm
an engineer without college so yeah it's
kind of cool and crazy that i get to
like because understudy and learn from
him how to be a developer advocate
seriously i think chris shawn is also
one of the first people that i talked to
when i started youtubing because he had
he's had his channel for longer than
mine and i think we like chatted online
and i was just like oh this is cool
there's like people here that i can talk
to so yeah i think he's probably one of
those figures in the tech youtuber
community who like does a good job of
reaching out to like new people it's
just like hey like come on hang out like
that he absolutely is just all over the
internet all corners of it he's up in
there that's how he found me for sure
well that's so exciting so yeah i do
have topics but a lot of it i mean i was
telling you before the show is just like
just chilling talking about youtube
interests and stuff first of all very
very important question
how the heck is your mechanical keyboard
do you still like it
oh my goodness it's amazing yeah i was
using this little flat guy thing and i
thought it was nice i liked it that's
why i learned how to use the mac
shortcuts and then i switched over to
the mechanical guy which is which is
this one and
i i underst i understand why people are
spending money time and making videos
around mechanical keyboards they're
amazing yeah i got into them in the last
few months too because i built my first
one like a couple months ago but i
didn't get my first one
until this year i think that was like
one of my 2021 highlights i think but
like i watched a video and you were you
did your first impression and then your
second first impression and your first
impression was like
it's cool
you know i don't love it but it's fine
and then your second first impression
was like i love it i've been using it
yeah it's great
i was talking to somebody oh so um my
ios developer academy someone was asking
one of the questions we got was like do
we need to get a mechanical keyboard is
that like a thing absolutely with
developers requirement yeah
and i was just like you don't have to
but it is one of those cultural things
that like it's just a thing for whatever
reason the developer community and then
they're like i just don't get it like
what what is it about mechanical
keyboards and i think i told them i was
just like i think you just gotta buy one
and use it for two weeks and then try to
go back to what you were using and your
life is gonna be changed like it's one
of those you don't
realize how good it is until you try it
for a long time and then you go back to
what you were doing and you're just like
no definitely that because i walked by
like the keyboard aisle in best buy
tippy tapped on a couple and i was like
well okay and i got mine tippy tapped on
it okay and like you said two weeks
later i was like okay yeah never turn
him back never ever turn him back can't
use a regular keyboard anymore i use um
this hhkb one that i made a video about
but yesterday i was using this logitech
like keyboard i think it's called the
k380 it's so honestly flex honest
i have all of the keyboards i might as
well make a keyboard rack or somewhere
in my room and this is cute and it's so
versatile and i was using it with my
ipad but it like i just i literally was
like i don't remember how to type
on this anymore that's how it feels
though i feel slower out of touch i
don't even know how to code anymore yeah
like also like my layout of my current
keyboard is a little bit different than
the logitech k380 so i literally was
just like not typing correctly and i was
just like what is happening to my brain
like i don't understand yeah i watch one
of your videos where you could like
change the configuration which i didn't
know was possible before my mechanical
keyboard js and i was like oh that's
awesome that's amazing yeah well okay
tell me about the keyboard that you do
have right now like let's talk specs
because a lot of my viewers listeners
love mechanical keyboards so
yeah i mean three weeks in i'm basically
the foremost professional on mechanical
keyboard so here i go
um i got the iq unix
um it is it has cherry red mx keys is
that how you say that i think so oh
yeah that's like the easiest one i saw
like a youtuber had the same keys i was
like
that one yeah and um it's heavy two
pounds and it's it's pretty is that the
best that's what you like
sorry that's good no i think that i was
mostly curious about your um key
switches which i only really know of two
kinds and i'm starting to learn what all
the different colors mean because i
think the very first time that i got a
mechanical keyboard i got cherry blues
which i didn't realize were the loudest
of the bunch and then i was like oh
right colors matter they're all
different because
like it's like hobby that everyone likes
i actually have no idea what the red
sound like but it sounds very like nice
and clicky but
these are the these are the reds
oh it sounds good it sounds i mean it's
sake
thaky is that a i'm gonna look that up
later and if it's not in the dictionary
we're gonna have some problems i've been
on our mechanical keyboards a bunch and
uh that's how that's the technical term
of how you describe the sound yes
i also get a lot of them like random
like 20 second mechanical keyboard
videos on my youtube algorithm now and
it's all just like how does this 10
keyboard sound more socky than my 300
one but you watch them though because
you're like hmm
yeah i'm like this is not something that
i've ever considered but you're right
how
extra talky you just get sucked in so
i'm glad you're enjoying it i feel like
uh you you and i are both kind of
mechanical keep newbies and we'll just
kind of venture into the world together
absolutely all right well okay now let's
talk youtube because uh i don't get to
talk to a lot of other tech lifestyle
youtubers because there's not a lot of
us out there there is not a lot yeah
yeah we've talked about this before i
think one on one and stuff but i wanted
to just like talk more in depth i
suppose especially as you're kind of
doing this whole
six month full-time youtube thing but
let's start with kind of what got you
started on youtube like watching you
you're such a natural at like
entertaining and being on the camera and
stuff like that so like tell me a little
bit of the background of like how you
got started your inspirations how you
think about video content just like
brain dump
all right so i think i'm like a perfect
mixture of my parents my mom pam peoples
is a radio talk show host so that's
where i get my communication from and
then my dad is a ex-veteran and as well
as a i.t specialist so i'm like right in
between
youtuber tech lifestyle person seriously
you were literally a mix of your parents
like but like in 2021 yeah that's so
cool do they encourage you to start
youtube
not really but i mean they encourage me
for everything they're super supportive
but actually the imposter syndrome video
is the first script that i ran past my
mom and she was like tweak this engage
here do similes and then i think that
was probably one of the best scripts
i've ever written for a video dude that
script was really good i was watching
and i was just like he definitely
scripted this right because like it's i
think your delivery was also great too
it sounded like you were just telling me
a story and it didn't sound like you
were reading off the script but i was
like you got mama people to thank for
that one dude yeah we've talked about
your mom before she i mean she's been a
radio host for a long time right
right yeah one day she did like a
contest to try to be on the radio and
then the radio station liked her and
that's what she's been doing for the
last 12 years i guess that's so cool
shout out to you so your mom's name is
pam
yeah pam peoples
that's amazing and then the whole
youtube thing i um so you and jarvis and
chris like you guys together inspired me
to get into tech um chris inspired me to
get into tech and then you and jarvis
inspired me to like document it and i
just wanted to show people like what i
was doing with tech and how i was
failing what i was learning at and just
see
and be just very transparent with the
world of the good things that i'm gonna
do and the bad things that i did
i absolutely love that like first of all
so honored that i have been a part of
your journey in all of this like never
would i have ever thought that
like there would be more youtubers that
came as a result of me being a youtuber
so thank you for having me in your life
it's weird to say that all right i know
secondly i think that's awesome like i
think especially in kind of the youtube
space and stuff like a lot of people
talk about like oh like we don't need
another beauty youtuber or a travel
youtuber or a camera youtuber or a tech
youtuber but i think what's great about
it is that everyone brings a different
flavor of their own life and talking
about the challenges that they've
experienced or what's on their mind or
what creative things come out of their
brain is just like different from person
to person so even if we make similar
types of content yours and my content
are inherently different like we
literally made keyboard videos like
same-ish time this year but they feel so
different even though we're in the same
vertical which i think is so cool so i'm
i'm just glad that you decided to take
that leap really and like documenting
that whole
like self-taught software engineering
journey too i think is incredibly
valuable for anybody who's wanting to
get into the space
right right and like my my start was
like
super intentional before i even started
recording i looked at someone who has
done it before the youtube thing and the
coding thing and i'm like how do i do
exactly what they did and then put my
own flavor on it so that's exactly what
i did i studied studied your videos i
studied jarvis videos and a lot of them
are similar and i felt bad at that at
first and then i went to like this web
conference and was like
people care about your opinion on
certain things and that's why these
videos keep getting certain views and
people like to hear other opinions on
the same topic 100
yeah like we're all so different and
there's so many
different ways to go into tech and also
just different ways to make youtube
videos and tell your own story so
yeah 100
that that's incredible
yeah i think uh
where did i where where was i where did
i want to go with this thought i also
woke up at 5 a.m today
because
which is
my brain is just like girl you've been
awake for six hours and it's not even
noon so it's a little bit like
sputtering in there but lunch is coming
no flip flip flop because i have a
question for you because i know you do
okay
i know you do youtube full time right
i've seen you on the internets a couple
times a year
how was it like trying to get your start
of like hey i don't work for a company i
don't got to be there at nine and i'm
now just my yuko and i work for myself
and i can wake up whenever because in my
first couple of weeks uh working for
myself it um has proven a bit
challenging just to stay on schedule
dude i completely fail you so like i
took like a
one and a half
two months well really it was
realistically like a little over a month
break between the end of my last job at
netflix and then like really starting
full time which like during that time i
literally was just like i'm not gonna
work all i'm gonna do is like cook and
clean hang out with my dogs do what i
wanna do and i wasn't even sure like i
didn't have like a date for like when i
was gonna start youtube but when i did
start youtube it was like okay like i'm
doing this felt a lot like i was just
soaring through the air with no life
jacket no roller coaster to sit on like
it felt like i just didn't have anything
to grab onto because there was no
structure versus like in a work setting
right it's just like okay you can ask
mentors you can ask your manager like
there's a probably a document of
expectations or like something that you
can plug into but like when i started i
was just like i have i have nothing no
one's going to give me the answer so
like my first reaction was to like okay
well let's just make some structure
let's like i know how to do my job as a
software engineer so let's bring some of
those things into my current work so i
started to do like sprint planning where
i was like what am i gonna do this week
like here are the tasks that i'm gonna
do like let's do a retro at the end of
the week to see how that went and i
don't have to worry about anybody else
now i guess team of one great
which did to help like i mean that's
still how i operate today
it's definitely relaxed it took me a
while to be okay with like waking up at
10 a.m and not like sweating because
like who is gonna hold me accountable
sort of like i mean unless i have
meetings with other people of course but
it was like it felt very like oh my gosh
like no one's i can't get fired because
i i'm my own boss and so like how do i
do stuff and yeah it's it's probably
honestly taken about a year like it
wasn't until like maybe summer of this
year where i felt like okay like i can
do what i want i can take vacation when
i want i can wake up late i can work
late like i my life is defined by me and
it took me a while to really feel
comfortable with that that's some good
foreshadowing for me it's okay take two
months off sorry everyone you're not
getting videos for two months and then
in a year it's gonna start to click
yeah yeah that's honestly like great to
hear though because like i actually did
look at your notion video and how you
structured like your personal business
and your communications and like tables
and stuff like that and i was like wow
notion is amazing ever since that day
i've been studying notion as well to
figure out like you know product
management type stuff but for myself
for sure yeah and like i take this a lot
from other youtubers that i've learned
how their kind of stuff works so like i
think that notion video is inspired by
alia abdull's notion video and also
thomas frank's notion video and they are
like production content houses like they
just pump out content and they're very
efficient at it and they're very good at
it
and so i took a lot from that and then
also like working at patreon i was able
to talk to or like understand how other
creators businesses worked and there was
a certain thing i was just like oh it's
a business and like tech is also
business and so like it's a similar sort
of like a lot of big content channels do
like quarterly planning or monthly
planning or like pro and every video is
a project or a product right and so it i
started to see the similarities there
and obviously everyone comes from not a
tech background but i think like there
is some sort of like universal truth
when it comes to like project management
i think that is common to videos and
tech in any other industry
yes it's weird i'm seeing like my my
technics all of my agile my retros all
of that mentality is like becoming
helpful in my personal content creation
so i have tech to thank for helping with
my youtube and youtube helps my tech so
that's kind of like a nice little
handshake of a
for sure sometimes i'm just like i am so
glad that i have a tech background
before i went into youtube because like
some of the intangible skills you're you
probably resonate with this of just like
you get really good at like studying and
learning things on your own because
that's literally what you're doing as a
software developer and so like when it
especially when it comes to like content
creation it feels a little bit like no
challenge is too big because at the end
of the day you can always google it you
can always practice it because that's
also what you do with code
absolutely yeah it's like it's very
daunting for sure but the people who are
software developers like to study things
like to learn little bits and pieces of
tips and tricks to accelerate
performance and productivity so yeah i
am excited when i don't know how to do
something on final cut pro or i'm
excited when i don't know how to do a
certain edit or film this thing and i
get to learn it because we know how to
use google for sure i mean the fact that
you were like i studied notion i studied
these videos like i think that's like a
that's a skill you know and i think like
having that curiosity or determination
to learn new stuff is greatly fostered
in like software development and so i
have no doubt that you're gonna like
you're gonna figure it out you're gonna
be fine well okay so like one thing i
want to know is where are you at right
now in your journey early november
are you you said you're like a few weeks
into your internship or like when are
you going to take your break like walk
me through that
all right so right now yeah early
november and i just started my vacation
time so i'm trying to use as much as my
60 days um a vacation before i start
stuff but it's not a real vacation
because i'm still figuring out how to
work with sponsors and and youtube and
do all that stuff so maybe i should take
a break but outside of that it's it's a
lot i have a plan to travel the world a
little bit
while i'm doing this youtube tech thing
so i'm selling my house which i'm gonna
document and do a little vlog about that
then i'm moving to
hawaii with my brother jacob who's my
second brother i have four brothers and
then after hawaii i'm moving to austin
texas and then after austin texas i'm
moving to
japan or switzerland we'll see and just
kind of taking an environment before i
like actually do developer advocacy full
time wow no big just japan or
switzerland like
who knows i'm young
you are this is such a good time to do
that too hopefully the borders stay open
and stuff with coven and all of that but
that's so exciting
it's exciting so hawaii is because your
brother lives there austin texas do you
have another family member you're just
like another brother yeah the actually
the eldest one who's also in tech is uh
in austin cool the one that you got uh
the mechanical keyboard for
yeah
[Laughter]
that's awesome that's so exciting when
when does this all kick off like when
when do you
when is this is all happening within a
two two month time frame or right yeah
oh my god um so i'm doing um like a
month and a half i'm just buying one-way
tickets so i'm doing a month and a half
in hawaii i think and then a month and a
half in texas before i head out to japan
or switzerland wow that's exciting and
then you're also just selling a house in
the middle of that no big deal just yeah
i just had a bunch of people come over
to you know do the landscaping uh mowing
and getting my house staged like with
the empty rooms because i i have empty
rooms now because my roommates have to
leave because i'm still in the house and
now it's a whole thing but yeah i want
to show people like the soft side of not
the soft side like the the side outside
of programming like i live a life and
it's an interesting life and i want to
show people how i'm getting ready to
sell a house how i'm moving across the
country and just vlog on the way dude i
would love to see that i mean selling
the whole like house buying selling
process is such like to me like an
adulting thing but it's like it's a
thing that most people go through once
or twice in their life at least and i
bought my house last year and it was
such a big learning curve and like good
experience thank you thank you uh
but it's like i i think that stuff is
really fun to watch i watch a lot of
like diy channels and like house real
estate sort of stuff so i'm excited to
see it yeah absolutely and when i first
got started with tech i wanted to have
the end goal of being in like real real
estate investing so this is kind of
exciting i'm going to get my hands hands
wet feet wet
something
and figure out how to like you know buy
property sell properties and try to
scale that to i can do that multiple
times have a tech career so i can invest
more into real estate so that one day i
can just do youtube and make videos
about buying houses selling houses and
stuff like that dude you're setting up
like a whole life right now this is like
the eve of like the rest of your life
yeah
hopefully it all goes to plan that's so
exciting and you're gonna like vlog
during your travels do a little bit of
travel vlogging and stuff like that yes
ma'am
that's so exciting and then during your
six months like tell us a little bit
about what you have in store during that
time you just could make a lot of videos
doing developer advocate stuff like what
sorts of stuff do you have in store
so i like to do like a like a one for me
one for you type of thing so i know a
lot of people
[Laughter]
rhymes with pg yeah so a lot of people
that follow me are like tech people but
i also like to venture outside of tech
to try my own thing so yeah i also have
to work to get a job after um my six
months because while youtube is great
you're probably not gonna be able to uh
get a house by yourself unless you're
making or been doing youtube for a
couple years
so i need to get a developer advocate
job but to get a developer advocate job
i need to study so i'll be studying and
showing things like that along the way
for sure yeah i also have a lot of fun
brothers my brothers are like super
funny when we get all of us in the same
room it's just easy content and super
generic not generic super genuine
that's so fun
i think yeah i think i've seen that
you've made some other like family vlogs
before of like your family trips and
whatnot so it sounds like a good time
with the people's family
absolutely
oh oh i was gonna ask so okay like i
think this is cool because like we're in
that niche of youtube where we don't
just talk about tech stuff like we we've
talked about
like what it means to be a software
engineer like what do we do in our life
like what's the best programming
language blah blah blah but like we also
mix a lot of
like what else is in our life right and
so like how do you think about that i'm
really curious like do you ever feel
like um like you only need to make tech
content or like like that that kind of
like being able to bring other topics
onto your own channel i know is like
attention for a lot of like us tech
lifestyle youtubers really anyone in
youtube that mixes like two or more
topics and stuff so walk me through that
tell me about that
yeah so when i was getting started from
the very beginning i always knew i
didn't want to silo myself in tech and i
wanted to initially start as a tech and
lifestyle i didn't know what lifestyle
was gonna be but i wanted to leave some
room to adventure sideways and not just
be siloed so again i studied you i
studied jarvis and i i really studied
jarvis like i call it his trojan horse
youtube theory where no one cares about
you until you give them a reason to care
about you so jarvis's reason was that he
wasn't tech but then he pivoted to
commentary videos and then when he
pivoted and he enjoyed it and he got
views he was like oh well this is okay
people found him because of tech but
they loved him because of his commentary
and jarvis himself that's what yeah 100
jarvis still texts me sometimes though
when people are just like where are the
tech videos like why should i make tech
videos anymore and it's just like hello
somebody does it anymore but his tech
videos were really good like they they
were top-notch i learned a lot from him
too like the comment the mix of comedy
specifically i thought was like super
good
perfect yeah i actually sent them an
instagram like we're not friends on
instagram but i send them an instagram
message every single time i have like a
youtube update like hey i'm um i'm
starting my youtube channel thank you
for the inspiration hey i just hit 25
000.
oh my gosh so because in the in the
future and maybe like three years i'm
planning we're gonna be friends he's
gonna look at him like oh this is weird
and then he's gonna put it away
that's so funny i mean i think role
models like jarvis are great to have and
for people to just like constantly like
pave the way like him
i i guess this is also self-serving
because i also like helped make this um
niche a little bit too but absolutely
yeah it's sometimes i'm just like
i i wonder i'm just like am i old news
am i like out of style anymore but then
i think about it i'm just like honestly
that's okay because like there's so many
cool youtubers that are up and coming
who are like doing cooler newer awesome
or funnier like amazing stuff uh who
have like way better skills than i do
that's not to say that i don't have the
skills it's just like it's different you
know and it i think it just makes
like that whole part of youtube richer
and funner even though that's not a word
it's definitely a word
i think you're doing like the same thing
as well like i watched a
15 minute video about you making rice
balls and i'm like i don't know i'm not
really interested in this but my ego has
just a way of talking that's enjoyable
and i would never in my life just watch
a 15 minute video about
what are they called
that's that's what i said you yeah yeah
i'm so glad you were i pronounced that
yeah it was amazing i made that video
and like the view count wasn't very high
but i was just like you know what
the 15 000 views that i got on it they
all learned something probably new and
15 000 people now love no now they know
that i like rice balls and that right
type of impact i want to have on the
internet
which is like honestly like a really
good indicator of like your super fans i
just read a book called super fans it
talks about who are the people in like
your audience that will follow you to
the ends of the world no matter what you
do so i like to like adventure the same
way you mentioned with those videos and
like hey what if i just made a really
weird video about socks but people watch
that
and then the people who do watch that i
get a good sense of okay those are my
super fans i have 300 super fans 400
super fans i've heard too like it only
takes 1 000 dedicated fans in order to
be able to do content creation full time
because though like that's your core
like group of people that you're like
catering to so
when i think about that i'm like dude
there's like so many other creators out
there who maybe don't have like 10
million subscribers or something like
that but are still doing it and are
really successful at it but on that note
like do you have like
i'm curious if you have any videos in
your mind that you're just like it would
be awesome to make this just because i
want to i don't know if it's the socks
video or like
so when i first got started i was living
in a santa monica los angeles area and i
actually was in between doing like a
lifestyle type of channel versus like a
um like a public prank type of channel
i'm not sure if you've seen that was
epic or cody cody strong vlogs whatever
but they like just go up to random
people and they just interact with them
they're like hey
what's your favorite color and then just
interact with random strangers or give
them money and see how they react i
really wanted to do that and that's
something i still might do in the future
but covet hit and i was like i guess uh
i'll make videos about coding yeah
what kind of like style do you think
you'd have like what kind of questions
would you ask
i would just i would just like to try to
make people
this sounds terrible like make people
uncomfortable with how forward i am
because i mean i am a forward person i
would just like go up to a stranger and
just like randomly start talking to them
so i just like want to like record those
interactions make them laugh make
everyone watching laugh and just have a
nice light-hearted type of videos i love
that i was interviewed on the street the
other day by like a random youtube
channel too
by like a man who's very tall and i was
wearing a mask and he was just like can
i buy your mask for one golden canadian
coin and i was just like no
and it was really awkward because i was
just like
like answering these questions really
logically and this guy was just like
towering over me and i was just like i
don't know what to do here even though i
i know what he's doing because like i
know how youtube works but also this is
like interesting and weird and then it
stayed on my mind for like the whole day
i'm pretty sure they're not gonna use my
footage but it was an interesting
experience to be a part of one for sure
from like the interviewed side yeah
there's a there's a right way to do that
and there's a wrong way to do it that's
why i was like trying to target or go on
like college campuses because more
college people are uh more likely to
engage with you and then the guy that i
watched who i again studied was that was
epic and he started off getting the
views in with like trying to get girls
numbers really funnily but now he's
doing super awesome thing where he gives
away like thousands of dollars ten
thousand dollars hey can i pay your rent
and they're like hey you want this car
like mr b style stuff and he got to do
that because of the number thing and i
think it's really cool to
like
be nice on camera and that be your
full-time job oh for sure there's that
one tick tock channel that's gotten huge
recently about the guy who like goes up
to random people in their cars like
luxury cars yeah
and they're like what do you do for a
living i love that because i always
wonder that when i go to like really
like nice like very mansion rich areas
i'm like what do all these people do for
a living like
how are there so many wealthy people and
what do they do
it's so weird now that like the people
in the cars used to be like the cool
people but now when he approaches them
they're like oh you're that guy and he's
just like holding an iphone i'm like wow
i know he like his reputation
succeeds exceeds him
like i think i remember there was one
where like there was a manager for like
some tick tock stars i think it was like
the manager of like charlie d'amilio is
that her name don't at me i'm a
millennial i don't watch tick-tock
but she was like oh i know who you are i
represent these tick-tockers give me a
call when you want management and i was
like wow
that the world's a weird place
so weird i mean if you do that i'm all
for it i feel like you give such like a
warm positive vibe uh that i would super
want to watch that kind of stuff so hope
you do that in hawaii or austin or
wherever you go too
except we'll see if you go to japan or
switzerland might encounter a bit of a
language barrier but you speak japanese
right i can pair with you get some
japanese under my bow and i'll be good
to go yeah just have me just just like
facetime me and just shove my face in
there in oh absolutely that's all i was
planning on doing yeah yeah yeah i'll be
there
i appreciate that
dude there's actually a um channel that
i've been obsessed with called um
konbini confessions and it's done by
this uh rapper he's like a japanese
rapper who grew up in new york city
and it's like a parody slash homage to
another
like
show
i don't remember what it's called i
think it's called no gas wait something
gas no brakes full gas snow breaks
something like that something like that
that's gas that breaks those cars yeah
it's it's like something that i think i
always wear a suit whatever but like he
goes to like middle of tokyo at like 2
a.m and interviews like drunk japanese
people and it's so interesting because
all the content on youtube about japan
is just like why japan is one of the
cleanest countries in the world why
japan has like children commuting on uh
like trains to go to their kindergarten
and it's all these like really orderly
sort of like why japan is clean and nice
and whatever but then these videos are
literally just like
drama like it's like it's these random
people who are super drunk who say
random stuff and i think it's hilarious
because i'm just like okay this is like
so different from what like yeah shake
up the algorithm yeah any ask random
questions like what's your favorite
color or like what would you do with a
million bucks or like would you prefer
this or that kind of stuff or like what
what are you looking forward to doing
when covet is over like it's all these
really basic questions and people
respond to it so randomly so yeah the
reaction type of content if you do it
right i think it can be a really good
type of absolutely video there's just so
many people on earth and i just want i
want to meet all of them i'm such a
people person and there's just there's
just so many great your last name is
peoples like yeah
yeah it is
amazing well okay to wrap up this has
been super fun uh like it's so fun
talking to jeremiah but i think it'd be
fun slash i always want to leave these
episodes hopefully viewers you've had
fun listeners you've had fun too but if
you've been going through a lot of big
life changes and stuff and i feel like
there is probably a nugget of advice in
there that you have for anybody who's
also thinking about making any big jumps
or leaps or is currently in the middle
of doing so do you have any advice for
those folks any words of wisdom that you
have
yeah i mean
life is big life is scary and it's it's
a lot to try to take on all at once but
you're never gonna learn until you you
try so i always preach fail early learn
often and get out there fail because
that's the only way you're gonna learn
and you got a lot of years so you're
probably gonna you're probably gonna
learn a lot you're not gonna get it
perfect the first try my first video was
terrible as my phone propped up against
the book with no lighting no audio and
it performed like the best out of my
whole entire channel and i never would
have started i never would have this
channel unless i propped that book up so
fail early learn often
i love that you can buy that on
jeremiah's merch store if you'd like to
support it somewhere because i just saw
your merch store and it's fire
yeah they actually haven't announced it
yet but i guess by the time this video
is up it'll it'll be up but um yeah
that's um what i say
yeah i uh you know the whole like iphone
propped up against the book thing is
interesting because also one of my most
like viewed videos i think it's the
uh six reasons why i love being a
software engineer video i think is
probably the second ever video that i
made is also
iphone propped up against a window video
funny how that works right i know i
watch it and i cringe and i'm just like
oh my god i don't know how to read the
audio the lighting yeah
same here i'm with you on that one
everything is bad but it's got like half
i think it actually might have a million
views at this point
so i i'm a hundred percent with you
there fail
early learn often is that what it is the
one that's the one my you go love it
well jeremiah thank you so much for
being on the show where can people find
you on the internet
i'm pretty much jeremiah peoples
everywhere besides twitter i'm we the
people's there you can find all of his
information in the description box down
below or in the show notes you can
listen to this episode of mooco's corner
as a podcast through your favorite
podcasting app thank you again so much
your mara i'm gonna have to have you on
the show again because i feel like we
can just talk for hours on whatever
stuff so best of luck to you thank you
for coming on and i'll talk to you soon
yeah thanks for having me